I think its a mix of both and I think
that that represents the future of what
the mixed capitalism kind of model is
the state ism that Europe has always
practice where corporations and the
government are very much in collusion
and what Asia has learned to do and does
itself at Korea and Japan and China are
doing is something that basically if you
take European economies and Asian
economies together it puts us in the
minority of players who have been
practicing real genuine free-market sort
of practices and economics in the last
decades so I think we're going to learn
to do things their way rather than vice
versa that speaks to a broader critique
of globalization which is that we don't
the countries don't want to have
unmanaged unfettered globalization they
want to regulate they want to have
capital controls they want to direct and
channel for an investment in certain
ways to serve their own national needs
and to build their infrastructure and so
forth that is the model that is
prevailing now in Asia because it's
proved to have great payoffs whereas the
free market model is what is blamed
correctly or incorrectly for the asian
financial crisis
you